A partir du verset 22, nous sommes en train de considérer le fruit de l'esprit.
C'est un fruit dans les sangliers, mais cette portion du passage commence par « mais ».
Ces mots qui visent porter du contraste, un contraste qui veut mettre en emphase contre quoi les fruits de l'esprit sont présentés,
mais un contraste qui vise aussi à donner davantage l'importance à ce qui sera considéré à partir de là.
Donc à chaque fois qu'on s'approche des écritures, c'est important de ne pas permettre qu'un texte sorte de son contexte.
Quelqu'un a déjà dit qu'un texte hors contexte est prétexte pour les hérésies.
Et malheureusement, plusieurs faux prophètes de nos jours vont sortir des versets, ou même juste une portion des versets,
pour justifier toutes sortes d'hérésies et d'interprétations publiques charnelles.
Donc pour nous, c'est très important pour enrichir notre compréhension,
de revenir dans les contextes tout large du passage et comprendre l'importance de l'introduction de l'apôtre Paul aux fruits de l'esprit.
Si on revient verset 13, et j'aimerais que vous ayez vos Bibles sous vos yeux,
pour que ça soit plus fluide, je vous rappelle.
La première chose, c'est que ces fruits de l'esprit, il a à voir avec cette vraie liberté dont l'apôtre Paul nous parle au verset 13.
Frères, vous avez été appelés à la liberté.
Donc les fruits de l'esprit, il est les saints esprits à l'origine de cette liberté,
car c'est le Saint-Esprit qui nous a appelés à cette liberté.
On est esclave du péché, on est esclave de la loi, on est esclave de la condamnation du péché,
on est esclave de la condamnation de ce que la loi exigeait.
Et donc, on a été affranchis par l'esprit.
Au moment de la conversion, c'est le Saint-Esprit qui nous a présenté notre coupabilité devant la loi,
de manière qu'aucun être humain, sous l'influence de la conviction du Saint-Esprit,
peut considérer qu'il a les moindres espoirs en soi-même par ses efforts avec la loi, avec la religion, et c'est sauvé.
Cette conviction de péché apportée par l'esprit a conduit à la considération du seul et vrai moyen d'être affranchi
de la condamnation du péché et de la condamnation de la loi, c'est-à-dire les Christs.
Par la foi à Jésus-Christ, l'obéissance parfaite du Christ, sa mort à la croix,
elle a payé parfaitement la double dette qu'on avait devant Dieu,
et toutes les exigences de la justice des dieux envers nous ont été pleinement satisfaites.
Et donc, à partir de cet appel du Saint-Esprit envers les Christs,
on a été appelé à la liberté.
Donc, la conversion a pour point de départ cet appel intérieur de Saint-Esprit
qui nous présente Christ à l'intérieur de chacun d'entre nous
et en comprenant son œuvre, on traverse cette répentance qui s'accroche à Christ.
En Jésus, nous trouvons tout ce dont on avait besoin pour être déclaré libre devant Dieu, pardonné,
et on n'est plus sous la condamnation de la loi,
on n'est plus sous la puissance dominatrice du péché.
Il y aura encore quelques restes du péché,
mais on est appelé à la liberté.
Et donc, c'est intéressant,
on a été délivré de la loi et délivré de la puissance dominatrice du péché
pour vivre la liberté.
La liberté doit être considérée, elle aussi,
comme un style de vie qui s'éporte vers Dieu.
Dieu nous a créés pour être son image.
La satisfaction de l'être humain ne se trouve pas ailleurs.
Nous ne pouvons qu'être vraiment satisfaits
lorsque nous réjouissons de cette liberté
de pouvoir avoir accès à Dieu,
celui qui est le seul à satisfaire nos âmes,
et mener la vie qu'il vit,
c'est-à-dire reproduire sa vie.
Les plus grands plaisirs, la plus grande ambition du vrai chrétien,
c'est de vivre la vie que Dieu vit.
Voilà pourquoi Paul est en train de dire,
frère, vous êtes appelé à la liberté,
seulement ne faites pas de cette liberté
en prétexte de vivre selon la chair.
Et là, c'est intéressant,
car ici nous sommes devant
une possible maladie spirituelle
qui devrait être exceptionnelle et remote,
et Paul vise à corriger la compréhension du chrétien.
Attention, on a passé de considérer
comment les saluts se passent,
à considérer qu'est-ce qui marque la vie d'un vrai chrétien.
Comment constater un vrai chrétien ?
Ne faites pas de cette liberté en prétexte
de vivre selon la chair.
Une mauvaise compréhension théologique,
attention, une compréhension théologique
non expérimentale,
non réelle,
artificielle,
peut mener
à un faux chrétien,
ou à un chrétien très malade,
à se dire, comme Christ a tout payé,
j'ai mes livres péchés.
Ce que Paul est en train de dire,
Dieu ne nous a pas affranchis
afin qu'on soit un nouveau esclave des plaisirs charnels.
Il nous a affranchis afin qu'on soit vraiment libres.
Libres pour aimer Dieu,
libres pour nous aimer,
libres pour mener la vie que Dieu vit.
L'accusation de ceux qui n'ont pas compris la loi,
c'est-à-dire les faux prophètes,
c'était,
si Paul met beaucoup d'emphase
sur les faits que Christ a tout payé,
les personnes vont se plonger dans les péchés.
Quel est le problème ?
Ces personnes n'étaient pas converties,
elles ne comprenaient pas comment la sanctification marche vraiment.
Et voilà pourquoi Paul peut porter cet impératif,
mais rendez-vous par la charité,
serviteurs les uns des autres.
C'est quoi la liberté ?
Être libre de l'égoïsme,
de la considération d'être des petits rois,
pour vivre la vie que Dieu vit.
Un Dieu serviteur.
Un Dieu qui vit pour la promotion de la vie des autres,
par amour.
Donc cet impératif,
il pointe déjà les présupposés
que celui qui a été affranchi,
qui a né de nouveau pour vivre la vie des dieux,
a la capacité de vivre librement dans cette direction.
Rendez-vous par la charité,
serviteurs les uns des autres.
La substance essentielle de la vraie liberté,
c'est l'amour.
L'amour pour Dieu,
qui produit l'amour pour les prochains.
Car toute la loi est accomplie.
Dans une seule parole,
tu aimeras ton prochain comme toi-même.
Donc la substance essentielle,
non seulement du vrai salut,
mais de la loi elle-même,
ce qui n'était pas compris par les légalistes,
par les judaïsants,
c'est l'amour.
Et voilà pourquoi personne n'arrive à accomplir la loi
par ses propres forces,
car elle n'aime pas Dieu comme il faut,
elle n'aime pas les prochains comme il faut,
elle porte une relation vers Dieu
comme si Dieu était tout simplement un tyran
qui cherche à trouver la moindre faute
afin de nous condamner ou de nous chasser.
Et au verset 15, il dit,
mais si vous vous mordez
et vous dévorez les uns les autres,
prenez garde
que vous ne soyez détruits
les uns par les autres.
Donc l'état de santé de cette église,
elle était vraiment grave.
À nouveau,
c'était une église
qui avait bien commencé
et qui naturellement vivrait sa liberté
de la manière correcte.
Par l'interférence des légalistes
qui ne connaissaient pas vraiment
de manière expérimentale
la foi qui sauve,
ils sont arrivés à la conclusion
qu'ils peuvent être
en plus de vivre cette vie naturelle
vers la sainteté,
ils devraient se focaliser
sur leur performance
envers la loi,
légalisme
et qu'ils avaient la possibilité
peut-être
d'être considérés
tout simplement
comme pas enfants des dieux
mais comme des cousins
des judaïsants,
des juifs convertis.
Ces païens-là,
par ces légalistes,
étaient convaincus
qu'ils devraient faire
quelque chose de plus.
Circoncision,
garder les dates,
leur performance,
leur observation de la loi.
Dans le monde évangélique actuel,
c'est
ces rapports envers Dieu
qui sont toujours basés
sur la performance.
Dieu va me bénir
si je ne rate pas
un seul service,
un seul culte.
Il faut faire
la campagne des 70 semaines.
Si je rate une,
si je ne suis pas béni.
Il faut que je fasse
des offrandes
en attendant
qu'il par mes sacrifices
je serai béni.
Et si je ne tiens pas bon
selon les traditions
et les coutumes de l'Église,
je peux risquer
de perdre mon salut.
Sauf qu'ici,
Paul est en train
de présenter
« mais le fruit,
l'esprit ».
C'est ce que Paul vise
à démontrer,
c'est que la réjouissance
de la vraie liberté
n'est ni
une vie légaliste
qui se sent toujours
menacée par la loi
avec la possibilité
de perdre le salut,
ni
la carnalité.
Les vrais chrétiens,
par sa nouvelle nature,
sous l'enfance
de son esprit,
ne sera pas dirigé,
ne se dirigira pas
dans la direction
du péché.
Et voilà pourquoi.
Mais,
les fruits de l'esprit
sont en contraste
envers le légalisme,
il est en contraste
avec le libertinage,
la carnalité,
car c'est un fruit
du Saint-Esprit
des dieux tout-puissants,
celui qui a engendré
la foi.
Et donc,
la première chose
qu'il faut reconnaître,
c'est que lorsqu'il peut
le viser à présenter
les fruits de l'esprit,
c'est qu'il est en train
de nous donner,
attention,
une base d'assurance
contre les hérésies
au sein de l'Église.
La relation expérimentale
avec le Saint-Esprit
rend les vrais chrétiens
capables
d'identifier
les faux prophètes
et les soi-disant
chrétiens charnels,
comme on n'est pas
étant des chrétiens
authentiques,
ils n'ont pas
cette influence.
Ils ne comprennent pas
les vrais évangiles,
car ils pensent
que nous dépendons
de la loi
pour nous maintenir
dans les saluts
ou pour ne pas
perdre les saluts.
Et ils pensent
que les influences
du Saint-Esprit
ne suffisent pas
pour ne pas nous conduire
à la carnalité.
Vous comprenez ?
Si nous avons
une expérience réelle
avec le Saint-Esprit
des saluts,
nous savons comment
le Saint-Esprit
agit en nous
par ses influences.
Et ça nous rend capable
de ne pas nous laisser
tromper par les légalistes
et ne pas nous laisser
tenter par les charnels.
C'est clair pour vous ?
Assurance du salut
importante
pour identifier
les faux enseignements
au sein de l'Église.
Ensuite,
si on continue
à lire les textes,
on arrive au verset 16.
« J'ai dit donc
marchez selon l'Esprit
et vous n'accomplirez pas
les désirs de la chair.
Car la chair a des désirs
contraires à ceux de l'Esprit
et l'Esprit a des contraires
à ceux de la chair.
Ils sont opposés entre eux
afin que vous
ne fassiez point
ce que vous voudriez. »
Donc ici,
c'est intéressant.
Ici,
Paul est en train
de faire les contrastes
entre les fruits
de l'Esprit
et cette bataille
qui marque
la vie chrétienne.
Ce qui est important
à remarquer
dans ses versets
16 à 18,
c'est que l'influence
prédominante,
attention,
dans la nouvelle nature
du vrai croyant,
c'est qu'il était né
pour Dieu.
Sa volonté,
la volonté
de sa nouvelle nature,
sa volonté prédominante
est la sanctification.
Voilà pourquoi
il est protégé
d'être tenté constamment
ou d'être plus tenté
par ses désirs charnels
qu'est par sa propre volonté
en tant que nouvelle créature
et par l'influence
de son esprit.
Donc ici,
la conscience
de la présence
de son esprit
dans nos vies,
c'est-à-dire
la connaissance
expérimentale
du salut
des tout vrais chrétiens,
attention,
c'est de savoir
que sa nouvelle volonté
se porte vers Dieu
et il sait très bien
que les appels
de la chair
portent contrairement
à la volonté
de Dieu.
Et en plus
de sa volonté
prédominante
envers Dieu,
il y a l'influence
du Saint-Esprit,
cette personne
qui habite en nous,
qui interagit avec nous,
qui est la troisième
personne de la Saint-Trinité,
qui est tout puissant
et qui pourvoit
ce qu'il faut
pour nous faire marcher
dans la bonne direction.
Donc,
pour plus
que la bataille
soit reconnue,
la bataille
de l'agriculture,
c'est clair
qu'il y a
une volonté
prédominante.
Et ici,
nous trouvons
l'une des bases
les plus importantes
de l'espoir,
de la non-excusabilité
du vrai chrétien.
C'est quelqu'un
qui ne va pas
longtemps
se livrer
au victimisme,
pour probabiliser
les tentations,
les circonstances
ou la carnalité,
qui ne va pas traiter
les péchés
comme si c'était
des maladies.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Il a déjà connu
par expérience personnelle
la présence des dieux
par son esprit
dans sa vie.
Il a expérimenté
une nouvelle naissance,
il sait dans quelle direction
il est porté
et même les moments
où il a des rechutes,
il est tellement gêné
par les Saint-Esprit
qu'il sait
qu'il ne peut pas
démarrer longtemps
dans les péchés.
Donc,
cette bataille réelle,
il doit connaître
quelles sont
les œuvres de la chair.
Voilà pourquoi
au verset 19,
on a pris du temps
pour considérer
les œuvres de la chair.
Mais quel était
l'intérêt de l'apôtre Paul
à manifester
ces œuvres de la chair
en contraste
avec les fruits
de l'esprit ?
Attention,
c'est car
il voulait
permettre
aux nouveaux croyants,
attention,
Paul n'est pas en train
de porter
des enseignements
complètement nouveaux.
Il est en train
de fournir
une aide
par ces paroles
pour que les croyants
soient capables
d'identifier
leur vie
dans cette histoire.
Quel est l'objectif
de Paul
en présentant
à nouveau
les œuvres
de la chair ?
C'est de permettre
aux Galates
qui étaient
sous l'assaut
des faux prophètes
qui voulaient
les convaincre
qu'ils devraient
maintenir leur salut
par leurs œuvres
que la chose
qu'ils devraient
identifier c'est
qu'est-ce que la loi
des dieux
vise à produire
chez vous.
Et quelle est
la condition
de celui
qui n'est pas
né de nouveau ?
Les œuvres
de la chair
visent
à communiquer
ceux qui sont marqués,
leurs vies sont marquées
par la prédominance
de ses péchés
dans leur vie.
C'est la pratique
constante
de leur vie.
Une vie
désintégrée
en toute direction.
Dans la sagette
de l'apôtre Paul,
ils visent
à convaincre
les Galates
qu'ils ne se trouvent
ni dans les groupes
des plus charnels
des légalistes.
Car quand on considère
les œuvres
de la chair
qu'Paul a évoquées,
il y a plein
de réproches
envers la vaine gloire
des légalistes,
leur animosité,
leur zèle
démesurée,
leur préoccupation
avec les dates,
la circoncision,
les habits,
etc.,
la tradition humaine.
Mais de l'autre côté,
il va évoquer aussi
les péchés passés
qui caractérisaient le plus
les cultures païennes,
l'idolâtrie,
la magie,
l'immoralité sexuelle.
Qu'est-ce qu'il veut
par là ?
C'est de dire
« mais les fruits
de l'esprit ».
C'est-à-dire,
vous avez connu
de manière expérimentale
et vous êtes capable
de reconnaître aujourd'hui
que lorsque vous êtes
des vents légalistes
en faux prophètes,
vous allez les retrouver
avec une vie
prédominamment marquée
par cet orgueil spirituel.
par ses rapports
envers Dieu
où Dieu n'est pas
un père d'amour,
c'est un tyran
qui vise à nous
coupabiliser,
où il n'y a pas
de progrès spirituel
sans la terreur
de la peur,
des pères de le salut.
Et de l'autre côté,
ces œuvres de la chair
manifestent aussi
l'immoralité
qui marquaient
la vie des Galates
dans leur passé.
Paul est en train
d'équiper les Galates
pour se dire
« nous ne les retrouvons
plus dans ces groupes.
Si jamais
je me retrouve
dans des rechutes
dans une de ces heures,
c'est ponctuel.
Je suis attristé,
ça ne dure pas longtemps.
Pour que les Galates
soient capables
de se dire,
on ne doit pas
entendre ces hommes. »
Donc,
l'assurance du salut,
il pourvoit
une manière
d'évaluer
la vraie foi
et nous voyons
la relation
entre la présence
du fruit de l'esprit
en nous
et l'assurance
qui nous permet
de ne pas
nous laisser
rendre esclaves
d'un rapport
d'esclave
envers Dieu
au lieu d'être
comme un enfant.
Et voilà pourquoi,
de manière plus immédiate,
l'apôtre Paul
au verset 21
va faire
je pense que vous dites
comment dites
en français
échec-match ?
Oui,
il va faire
un échec-match ici.
Car à la fin des comptes,
l'œuvre
de Saint-Esprit
a pour but,
l'un des buts principaux
c'est d'assurer
les croyants
qu'il est vraiment sauvé
non seulement
par les changements
de vie
qu'il a expérimentés
et par la considération
que ces changements
de vie
ont eu lieu
dans les cadres
de l'amour.
et la conviction
d'une adoption,
d'un amour paternel
des dieux
envers un enfant
des dieux.
Et donc,
au verset 21,
il va dire
je vous dis d'avance
comme j'ai déjà dit
que ceux qui commettent
telle chose
n'hériteront point
les romains des dieux.
Donc,
les termes à nouveau
héritage,
c'est pour nous rappeler
que ce ne sont pas
des conditions
pour être sauvés,
c'est plutôt
pour nous rappeler
que nous sommes plutôt
en train de constater
celui qui a été fait
né de nouveau,
a été fait
enfant des dieux,
des rebelles
qu'il était avant.
C'est une question
d'hériter une promesse,
ce n'est pas une question
de conquérir
une récompense.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et c'est d'hériter
car nous avons été fait
enfant des dieux
par la foi
en Jésus-Christ.
Donc,
lorsqu'on cherche
à observer
les caractères
d'un croyant
ou sa manière
de vivre,
son style de vie,
lorsqu'on cherche
à s'assurer
envers nous-mêmes
qui ne sommes pas
dominés par les péchés
mais qui nous progressons
envers les fruits
de l'esprit,
c'est plutôt
pour chercher
des évidences
convaincantes
que nous avons été
régénérés,
qui nous avons été
sauvés.
Ce ne sont pas
des conditions
pour être sauvés,
ce sont des conditions
pour être assurés
de salut.
Mais au cœur
de cette assurance
de salut,
il y a les ministères
du Saint-Esprit
qui ont été envoyés
par Dieu
avec le but
de nous assurer
de notre salut.
Non seulement
il doit générer
les saluts
et tous les vrais
croyants
doivent avoir
une mesure suffisante
d'être convaincus
d'avoir été visités
par les Saint-Esprits
et d'avoir compris
spirituellement
l'Évangile
car les choses
spirituelles
se discernent
spirituellement
mais la permanence
et la maintenance
de sa vie
est marquée
par cette influence
expérimentale
de Saint-Esprit.
Et voilà pourquoi
lorsque nous pensons
à l'assurance
du salut
et l'emphase
biblique mise
sur l'importance
de l'assurance
du salut,
nous pouvons remarquer
qu'au cœur
de cette assurance
c'est la conviction
d'avoir été fait
enfant de Dieu.
qui sont
ces autorités
soi-disant apôtres
dans le jour
dans les cadres
des Galates
pour vous porter
des anciennes convictions
ou des nouvelles convictions
qui s'éloignent
de la compréhension
expérimentale
et de la compréhension
bien sûr
théologique
biblique
du Nouveau Testament.
Ils ne sont rien
car ils ne sont pas
des vrais
enfants des dieux.
Un vrai
enfant des dieux
il connaît mieux.
Il ne se laisse
pas rendre
esclave
par ces types
d'influence.
Donc l'aspect
le plus important
l'aspect
tout inclusif
de cette assurance
le but central
du Saint-Esprit
c'est de porter
cette assurance
des filiations.
Comme dit
Lloyd-Jones
les dons
même Satan
peut dissimuler.
Les grâces
c'est impossible
pour un seul instant.
Les grâces
du Saint-Esprit
la présence
les caractères
changés.
Et donc ici
c'est intéressant
quand on pense
à l'importance
de la assurance
du salut
dans la Bible
nous voyons
qu'elle est déterminante
par exemple
pour que nous
soyons convaincus
d'avoir traversé
une expérience
des conversions
les moments
où je me suis converti
je sais
que je ne suis pas
arrivé à la connaissance
de l'évangile
qui est par la théorie
ou par la théologie
et pour plus
que la Bible
nous donne
beaucoup
d'arguments logiques
pour nous assurer
de notre salut
c'est-à-dire
celui qui croit
ne sera pas
condamné
et je peux me dire
je crois
donc je suis convaincu
logiquement
que je ne serai pas
condamné
pour plus
que la Bible
me donne
des arguments
théologiques
qui me montrent
que les évidences
des transformations
doivent être rajoutées
aussi logiquement
à mon assurance
du salut
a été surtout
envoyé
avec les buts
de communiquer
à nos esprits
de manière immédiate
et expérimentale
que nous sommes
enfants des dieux
c'est dans la même
longueur d'onde
si on peut dire
comme ça
que c'est dont
l'apôtre
est en train de parler
ici
les fruits
l'esprit
si l'esprit
il est là
ses influences
se portent
dans sa direction
et nous ne sommes
pas là tout simplement
pour essayer
de voir si la joie
la paix
ou l'amour
sont présents
de manière superficielle
dans ma vie
mais de voir
que cette réalité
c'est nouveau
caractère
cette présence
des dieux
en moi
se porte
organiquement
comme fruit
de l'esprit
car la troisième
personne de la trinité
entretient
une relation
personnelle
intime
avec moi
affectif
et tous les croyants
doivent avoir
une mesure
des connaissances
expérimentales
de ces réalités
c'était la doctrine
la plus exploitée
par les légalistes
chez les Galates
et la doctrine
la plus exploitée
par les catholicismes
surtout au Moyen-Âge
comme disaient
les réformateurs
la doctrine
qu'ils haïssent
les plus
c'est la doctrine
de l'assurance
du salut
car à partir
du moment
où nous ne sommes
pas rassurés
d'être des vrais
enfants
nous menons
une vie
envers Dieu
comme si on était
encore des esclaves
toujours
en déficit
en essayant
de compenser
nos fautes
pour conquérir
l'amour
des dieux
avec la peur
d'être virés
à n'importe quel moment
et c'est exactement
de cette manière
qu'on devient
des proies faciles
aux faux prophètes
aux légalistes
et donc
nous devons chérir
cette doctrine
et l'objectif
de l'apôtre Paul ici
c'est de démontrer
comment le Saint-Esprit
a pour but
de travailler en nous
de manière
à nous convaincre
qui nous sont menés
de nouveau
et nous donner
des capacités
pour identifier
son influence
en nous
surtout
par son fruit
quel est
le fruit
de toute l'emphase
légaliste
des judaïsants
chez les Galates
dispute
querelle
animosité
méfiance
un esprit
d'esclavage
par contre
ce que Paul pose
aux Galates
ok vous êtes
sous leur influence
mais quoi dire
de l'influence
de l'esprit
dans vos vies
dans quelle direction
elle se porte
est-ce que vous êtes
en train de vous porter
aujourd'hui
tel que le Saint-Esprit
produit en vous
ses fruits
ou est-ce que notre vie
est plutôt marquée
par ses mauvaises compréhensions
donc l'argument
de l'apôtre Paul
c'est de dire
plus ou moins
si vous êtes sûr
de votre filiation
d'être l'habitation
du Saint-Esprit
des dieux
tout va bien aller
remarquer
sa prédominance
dans vos vies
son influence
combien il produit
en vous
les caractères
des dieux
combien il entretient
votre relation filiale
avec les pères
votre union vitale
d'amour
avec les Christ
et donc
la vérité centrale
pour nous
que nous sommes
en train de considérer
c'est que
les fruits de l'esprit
est une évidence
nécessaire
et suffisante
pour identifier
un vrai héritier
des dieux
elle est nécessaire
et suffisante
et la question
qui va nous aider
à développer
cette compréhension
c'est comment identifier
les fruits de l'esprit
dans nos vies
on est en train
de considérer
avant de rentrer
dans chaque camp
de ces éléments
qui composent
les fruits de l'esprit
nous sommes en train
de considérer
quelle est la nature
et les fonctionnements
du fruit de l'esprit
et ce qu'on a déjà vu
c'est que
les fruits de l'esprit
sont organiques
organiques
c'est-à-dire
les fruits
donc
il s'est présenté
comme un fruit
car c'est quelque chose
qui coule
naturellement
de l'influence
de saint-esprit
dans nos vies
sans les saint-esprit
pas possible de l'avoir
avec les saint-esprit
impossible
de ne pas l'avoir
ok
et donc
c'est pour faire contraste
avec oeuvre de la chair
des choses qu'on peut produire
de nous-mêmes
c'est de nous rappeler
c'est qu'il est par l'esprit
et certainement par l'esprit
que ces fruits
sont produits
ensuite
on a considéré aussi
qu'il est spirituel
ce n'est pas
les fruits
de notre tempérament
ce n'est pas
les fruits
de notre diligence
ce n'est pas
les fruits
de notre religion
ou de notre performance
religieuse
c'est les fruits
de son esprit
donc
quand on regarde
l'amour
la joie
la paix
la patience
nous ne pouvons pas
les voir
comme on est
tout simplement
les tempéraments
comme si on était
en train de considérer
un chien
qui est plus calme
plus doux
ou un chien
qui est plus agressif
nous ne pouvons pas
non plus confondre
en fait
dans quelle direction
nos constitutions
particulières vont
par exemple
il y a des personnes
qu'on va se dire
il est très calme
il est pacifique
car il est toujours
en train d'éviter
les disputes
mais la réalité
c'est que
cet amour
cette douceur
cette paix
est liée
à la fidélité
à la tempérance
à la bonté
c'est à dire
ça ne peut pas être
une paix
qui veut tout simplement
éviter les disputes
à tout prix
car parfois
les disputes
mènent à la ruine
à la mort
et si les enjeux
sont la vie
ou les saluts des personnes
ces personnes
ne vont pas se faire taire
et donc
ce n'est pas quelqu'un
qui est toujours
en train d'éviter
les disputes
c'est quelqu'un
qui cherche
la vraie paix
la paix avec Dieu
la vraie réconciliation
c'est quelqu'un
qui aime
véritablement
c'est quelqu'un
qui veut voir
changer dans la vie
de personne
c'est donc
les personnes
doivent changer
pour être
dans la joie
dans la paix
dans le vrai amour
et donc
on n'est pas devant
tout simplement
des caractères
qui puissent être
considérés
comme des caractères
naturels
c'est spirituel
car
ils sont les fruits
du ministère
du Saint-Esprit
c'est-à-dire
c'est les fruits
de la connaissance
de Dieu
et ce sont des fruits
naturels liés
à l'expérience
des conversions
c'est-à-dire
je suis né
de Dieu
né pour Dieu
et donc
l'amour
est un amour
qui est lié
à l'amour
pour Dieu
un non-chrétien
n'a pas cet amour
vous comprenez ?
donc un non-chrétien
ne peut pas avoir
ses vertus
ce sont des vertus
exclusives
aux chrétiens
car
elles dépendent
du Saint-Esprit
c'est la manifestation
de la personne
de Dieu
c'est la manifestation
de notre union vitale
avec Christ
et elle se manifeste
de cette manière
elle est spirituelle
elle est aussi
et c'est la troisième chose
qu'on a vue
le dimanche dernier
le Saint-Esprit
il est indivisible
donc ici
nous ne sommes pas
devant
plusieurs fruits
on est devant
un seul fruit
car ces fruits
pour plus qu'ils soient
décrits
par ces facettes
harmoniques
équilibrées
et qui ne sont même
pas exhaustives
pour plus qu'on puisse
comprendre certains ordres
ils sont tous interliés
c'est impossible
d'avoir un véritablement
sans avoir les autres
tous dépendent
l'un de l'autre
et si vous voulez
en fait
considérer
moi je pense que
la clémentine
des fois
est une bonne illustration
mais tout c'est interlié
surtout par les premiers
qui ont l'amour
et la réalité
c'est qu'ils sont
inséparables
indivisibles
car c'est la manifestation
du caractère de Dieu
lui-même
dans nos vies
à travers nos vies
ils sont
ils ont tous
des connotations
qui remplissent
la notion
du schéma
aimer Dieu
de tout notre coeur
de toute notre pensée
de toute notre force
de toutes nos émotions
bam
donc ils sont tous
des natures
profondément spirituelles
qui exigent
notre compréhension
logique
qui engage
nos affections
et qui se manifestent
dans la pratique
et donc c'est tout simplement
la symétrie
du caractère glorieux
du Christ
c'est la vie des dieux
se manifestant
et voilà pourquoi
ils sont indivisibles
dans certaines périodes
de nos vies
peut-être que
certaines de ces facettes
sont moins visibles
mais le Saint-Esprit
sera toujours
en train de nous gêner
s'il y a la moindre facette
qui soit manquante
et il sera toujours
en train de travailler
pour la restaurer
et aujourd'hui
nous allons considérer
encore deux autres aspects
le premier
c'est que les fruits
de l'esprit
sont un fruit
permanent
j'aimerais vous inviter
à ouvrir vos bibles
en Jean
chapitre 14
verset 15
c'est le fruit
de l'esprit
ce qu'on doit comprendre
dès le départ
c'est que
le Saint-Esprit
n'est pas
supprimable
de la vie
de celui
qu'il a
véritablement reçu
pour tous ceux
qui ont reçu
le Saint-Esprit
de manière salvatrice
il ne va plus jamais
disparaître
le Saint-Esprit
si quelqu'un
et voilà
les grands problèmes
de l'église
aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elle
considère
comme des vrais
croyants
ceux qui
n'ont pas
manifesté
des évidences
suffisantes
pour nous convaincre
qu'ils sont sauvés
et on pousse
les personnes
à l'autel
pour répéter
une prière
on pousse
les personnes
envers les baptêmes
chrétiens
mais qui n'avaient
jamais été
vraiment converties
comme la Bible
nous enseigne
c'est loin
de l'église
définitivement
qui réunit
les Christs
l'explication
biblique
ils sont sortis
de notre milieu
mais ils n'étaient
pas des nôtres
pour que tu saches
que ni tous
ceux qui sont
entre nous
sont des nôtres
la même explication
de Christ
de la foi
éphémère
qui n'est jamais
la vérité
il y a une seule
foi véritable
dans la parabole
des terrains
et ce qui nous
voit ici
c'est la description
du Christ lui-même
dans ces passages
de Jean 14
remarquez bien
combien cette promesse
elle est universelle
pour tous les croyants
et elle est
irrévocable
d'ailleurs
c'est la plus grande
promesse
de l'Ancien Testament
envers la Nouvelle Alliance
c'est une promesse
qui ne pouvait pas
être donnée
aux vrais chrétiens
si Christ
n'avait
tout accompli
et de considérer
que cette promesse
puisse être révoquée
par nous
c'est de considérer
que Christ
n'a pas fait
tout ce qui était nécessaire
et donc c'est intéressant
de remarquer
il dit ici
Jean 14
verset 15
si vous m'aimez
gardez mes commandements
donc il y a une liaison
claire
entre ceux qui aiment
vraiment Christ
et la manière
dont il vit
et moi
je prierai
les pères
et il vous donnera
un autre consolateur
à fois qu'il
demeure
quel est le mot
éternellement
afin qu'il demeure
tant que vous vous
maintenez dans votre
obéissance
tant que vous respectez
les règles antérieures
de l'église
l'usage
les coutumes
de l'église
tant que vous ne ratez pas
les mercredis du réveil
afin qu'il demeure
éternellement
avec vous
quel est l'esprit
qu'on va recevoir
c'est l'esprit
des vérités
le seul contraste
qu'il y a
entre ceux qui l'ont
et ceux qui n'ont pas
c'est les contrastes
entre les vrais croyants
et les mondes
regardez
l'esprit de vérité
que les mondes
ne peuvent recevoir
parce qu'ils ne les voient
point
et ne les connaissent
mais vous
vous les connaissez
qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire
par là ?
ça c'est très important
les termes connaître
dans la Bible
il n'est pas qu'une connaissance
théorique
théologique
c'est une connaissance
expérimentale
c'est la capacité
de savoir reconnaître
vous les connaissez
quelle est la base
de cette connaissance
car il demeure
avec vous
et il sera
en vous
pendant les ministères
du Christ
les croyants
qui étaient autour
du Christ
ils avaient déjà
les privilèges
d'avoir les Saint-Esprit
bien présents
comme chez les vrais
croyants
dans l'Ancien Testament
la différence
c'est qu'ils connaissaient
déjà
car c'était les Saint-Esprit
par exemple
qui avaient ouvert
la compréhension des pierres
heureux est-toi
Simon
fils de Jonas
car c'est
Nishia
ils sont
qui ont révélé
cela
mais mon Père
qui est au ciel
il demeure avec vous
mais il sera
en vous
impossible
de ne pas connaître
de manière expérimentale
le Saint-Esprit
si nous sommes
véritablement sauvés
je ne vous laisserai pas
orphelon
je viendrai
à vous
donc de quelle manière
le Christ
viendra à nous
par le Saint-Esprit
c'est l'Esprit
du Christ
quel est l'Esprit
qui habite en nous
c'est l'Esprit
du Seigneur Jésus
lui-même
quel est l'objectif
de cet Esprit
n'est pas
nous laisser orphelon
nous assurer
que nous sommes
enfants des dieux
non seulement
on est exposé
à un examen
des écritures
très critérieux
pour voir
combien de cases
on peut crocher
dans notre connaissance
théorique
c'est de nous demander
est-ce qu'à un moment donné
dans ma vie
le Saint-Esprit
de Dieu
m'a parlé directement
et quand je dis parler
c'est pas forcément
par une voix audible
mais il a imprimé
ses convictions
spirituelles
dans mon coeur
peut-être par une prédication
peut-être par la lecture biblique
peut-être dans sa liberté
même
de manière audible
pour certains
il a dit
je ne vous laisserai pas
au phénom
je viendrai à vous
encore un peu de temps
et le monde ne verra plus
mais vous
vous me verrez
car je vis
et vous vivrez aussi
dans ce jour-là
vous connaîtrez
que je suis
en mon Père
que vous êtes en moi
et que je suis en vous
en Christ en nous
par les consolateurs
c'est lui qui a
mes commandements
et qui les garde
c'est lui qui m'aime
et celui qui m'aime
sera aimé
de mon Père
je l'aimerai
et je me manifesterai
à lui
les manifestations
du Christ
sont promises
aux croyants
vous êtes avec moi ?
la vraie vie chrétienne
n'est pas une question
d'une connaissance
à propos du Christ
c'est une connaissance
expérimentale du Christ
à l'intime de nos cœurs
il est en nous
il demeure en nous
éternellement en nous
et les influences
de son esprit
c'est de manifester
Christ
en nous
on va sauter
au verset 25
je vous ai dit
ces choses
pendant que je demeure
avec vous
mais les consolateurs
de l'Esprit Saint
que le Père
enverra en mon nom
vous enseignera
toutes choses
et vous rappellera
tout ce que je vous ai dit
une partie
de ces promesses
sont spécialement
consacrées
aux vrais apôtres
car ils devraient
établir la fondation
de la foi
et fondement
ils devraient écrire
les nouveaux testaments
pour qu'on n'ait plus
jamais besoin
des apôtres
que ce soit clair
mais en plus
c'est une promesse
universelle
et la réalité
c'est qu'il
par les ministères
ordinaires
de l'Église
par nos relations
personnelles
avec le Saint-Esprit
il continue
de faire ces choses
dans nos vies
remarquez bien
il a beaucoup
parlé
d'amour
il a parlé
d'instruction
donc cette fidélité
cette fiabilité
et c'est 27
maintenant il parle
de la paix
je vous laisse
la paix
je vous donne
ma paix
je ne vous donne
pas comme
le monde
donne
vous comprenez
que les vrais
chrétiens
peuvent connaître
cette paix
peuvent expérimenter
la paix
d'être enfant
de Dieu
de manière
irrévocable
vous avez entendu
ce que je vous ai dit
je m'en vais
et je reviens vers vous
si vous m'aimez
vous vous réjouirez
de ce que je vais au Père
car le Père
est plus grand que moi
et maintenant
je vous ai dit ces choses
avant qu'elles arrivent
afin que lorsqu'elles arriveront
vous croirez
donc
que vous vous réjouirez
que je vais vers le Père
comment les apôtres
comment les disciples
auraient pu se réjouir
sachant qu'il est Christ lui-même
sortirait du cadre
direct
objectif
visible
de leur relation
c'est car
si les Christ
ne montent pas
le Saint-Esprit
ne peut pas être envoyé
quelle est la source
de la joie
la vraie joie
de chrétiens
le Saint-Esprit
c'est une promesse
universelle
l'évangile des gens
au chapitre 7
verset 38
nous dit
c'est lui qui croit
en moi
c'est Christ lui-même
qui dit
des fleuves d'eau vive
couleront de son sang
comme dit l'Écriture
j'espère que ça soit clair
pour vous
l'objectif
c'est d'être sûr
que la venue
du Saint-Esprit
était une promesse
capitale
pour la vie chrétienne
une promesse
permanente
universelle
et une promesse
profondément
expérimentale
la description
ici c'est
des fleuves
d'eau vive
couleront de son sang
comme dit l'Écriture
verset 39
de quoi il parle
il dit cela
de l'esprit
qui devait recevoir
ceux qui croiraient en lui
car l'esprit
n'était pas encore
parce que Jésus
n'avait pas encore
été glorifié
les témoignages
distinctifs
des chrétiens
dépend aussi
de la présence
de son espèce
c'est-à-dire
quel est l'essence
d'être
après la conversion
quelle est l'utilité
pour Dieu
et pour nous
quel est l'avantage
d'après avoir été converti
n'est pas être renvoyé
à la gloire
déjà tout de suite
mourir
c'est un gant
quelle joie
pouvons-nous encore
attendre de cette vie
si nous avons déjà goûté
la joie suprême
être avec Christ
donc la seule
chose
qui peut faire
que nos vies
soient considérées
d'une valeur
comme l'apôtre Paul disait
je ne considère
ma vie
de plus aucun gant
pour moi-même
si ce n'est que
servir à Christ
et donc ici
c'est intéressant
qui peut témoigner
à propos du Christ
remarquez bien
les témoignages
d'un chrétien
n'est pas
les témoignages
tout simplement
de celui
on sait très bien
ce n'est pas
celui qui a tout simplement
entendu parler
ok vous êtes avec moi
un témoin
c'est celui
qui a vu
des premières mains
la foi
de ma mère
de ma grand-mère
a pu jouer
un grand rôle
à partir du moment
de ma conversion
mais elle n'était pas
capable
de produire
d'elle-même
ma conversion
vous êtes avec moi
et pour plus
que j'ai une connaissance
théorique
de l'évangile
je ne peux pas
être un témoin
car je n'ai pas
encore vu
de mes propres yeux
vous êtes avec moi
un témoin
c'est celui
qui va parler
avec authenticité
avec naturalité
avec autorité
c'est à dire
il a été couvert
de courage
car il a contemplé
les Christ lui-même
au moment de sa conversion
il ne parle pas
des choses
dont il a entendu parler
il a expérimenté
cette réalité
mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les chrétiens
ne sont même pas
tout simplement
ceux qui ont
vu
nous sommes
ceux
à travers
qui Dieu
s'est fait voir
vous êtes avec moi
par les fruits
de l'esprit
c'est à dire
par la présence
du Christ
dans nos vies
il fait de nous
des petits Christ
et au moment
où on manifeste
les vertus
du Christ
par notre vivre
les personnes
se sont proches
de Dieu
c'est comme si
Paul disant
2e Corinthiens 5
comme si Dieu
exhortait
à travers nous
on vous insouplit
voilà pourquoi
c'est important
et c'est pas
de la nature humaine
de donner l'écoute
à ceux qui ont
les bonnes paroles
mais leur vie
ne peut pas
supporter
leur témoignage
les faux prophètes
disent l'apôtre Paul
disent connaître
l'évangile
mais nie
la puissance
ils nie la puissance
c'est quoi la puissance
on donne du crédit
à ceux qui vivent
de manière cohérente
à ce qu'ils prêchent
nous devons être
celles de la terre
pour pouvoir fonctionner
en tant que lumière
du monde
on ne peut pas
couper la gorge
du serment
en manifestant
des dons
spirituels
à gauche
et à droite
dans un culte
des réveils
et maltraiter
nos enfants
nos épouses
ou les serviteurs
au resto
lorsqu'on sort
du boupitre
ces caractères
symétries
la vertu
du Saint-Esprit
les fruits
doivent se manifester
dans la vie
pour que
la parole
de l'évangile
soit couplée
à la puissance
de l'évangile
voilà pourquoi
dans ces passages
actes 1
verset 7 et 8
ce n'est pas à vous
de connaître
les temps
ou les époques
que les pères
ont fixé
de sa propre autorité
ce n'est pas à vous
d'être là
en train de vouloir
découvrir
la date
du retour du Christ
mais vous recevrez
une puissance
faites ce qu'il faut faire
pour qu'il revienne
ne soit pas préoccupé
les jours
de son retour
mais vous recevrez
une puissance
les Saint-Esprit
survenant sur vous
et vous serez
mes témoins
à Jérusalem
dans toute la Judée
en Samarie
et jusqu'aux extrémités
de la terre
c'était une promesse
faite
et l'église
a grandi
sur cette base
pas que les apôtres
prêchants
le Saint-Esprit
est descendu
et toute la communauté
n'a fait qu'érandir
était très engagée
dans l'évangélisation
dans cette croissance
explosive
de l'église
après la venue
du Saint-Esprit
tous ont reçu
le Saint-Esprit
tous les vrais chrétiens
et les buts
de cette permanence
de Saint-Esprit
c'est notamment
de produire en nous
l'assurance
du salut
quel est le ministère
central du Saint-Esprit
c'est de révéler
Christ en nous
au moment de la conversion
c'est de révéler
Christ en nous
c'est de nous former
en conformité
avec le Christ
c'est de nous assurer
du salut
Romains 8
14 et 18
car tous ceux
qui sont conduits
par l'Esprit des dieux
sont fils des dieux
c'est pas une condition
mais faire conduire
par les Saint-Esprits
afin d'être fils des dieux
c'est un constat
si nous voyons
une personne
qui est conduite
dans sa vie
par les Saint-Esprits
nous sommes des vents
en fils des dieux
et vous n'avez point reçu
un esprit des servitudes
pour être encore
dans la crainte
mais vous avez reçu
un esprit d'adoption
par lesquels
nous crions
Abba Père
comme je vous ai dit
en écoutant
la prédication
en disant la Bible
je me rappelle très bien
un moment de réveil
dans ma foi
c'était déjà
après ma conversion
mais une œuvre
intensifiée
dans le Saint-Esprit
dans mon cœur
au moment où j'ai compris
qu'à la croix du calvaire
Jésus-Christ n'était pas
en train de mourir
tout simplement
pour les mondes
il m'est porté
moi-même
dans son cœur
mon nom
était écrit
dans ses mots
dans sa patrine même
et c'est le Saint-Esprit
qui peut faire
usage
d'une littérature chrétienne
de la parole
de Dieu
d'une prédication
d'un conseil
d'un ami
pour imprimer
dans nos cœurs
cet amour
particulier
de Dieu
en tant que père
de moi-même
en tant que fils
on n'a pas reçu
un esprit
de servitude
vous voyez
les contextes légalistes
ils ont besoin
de ces
ces émotions fortes
cette terreur
de sentir
l'adrénaline
des menaces
ils pensent avoir
besoin de ça
et la réalité
c'est que
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
il vient vraiment
il va imprimer
dans nos cœurs
la conviction
que la relation
avec Dieu
n'est plus passible
du manque
d'assurance
quelle est
la relation
entre la réussite
même de notre éducation
vers nos enfants
et la capacité
de porter cet équilibre
on verra plus tard
que
l'un des recours
utilisés par le Saint-Esprit
c'est la discipline
Dieu
discipline celui
qui l'aime
donc ne soyez pas
préoccupés
si vous pensez
que vous avez besoin
d'être terrorisé
par la possibilité
de la perte du salut
car Dieu
saura
la mesure exacte
des souffrances
qu'on doit traverser
pour corriger
certaines choses
dans nos vies
est-ce qu'il manque
dans nos vies aujourd'hui
plus d'amour pour Dieu
pour les prochains
plus de bénignité
des générosités
envers les personnes
plus de douceur
plus de patience
Dieu saura
développer
même par la discipline
ces choses
dans nos vies
mais Dieu n'a pas besoin
de nous terroriser
comme si on allait
perdre le salut
comme s'il allait
nous virer
vous comprenez
la relation ici
elle est très claire
c'est
l'esprit de Dieu
qui avait été envoyé
qui a été envoyé
par Dieu
les Pères
afin de travailler
dans nos âmes
pour nous conduire
envers Dieu
et oser
de dire
papa
vous pouvez oser
de dire papa
ou même
lorsque vous dites
papa
vous avez plutôt
l'impression
que vous êtes en train
de manquer
de respect
et certes
c'est pas un papa
charnel
comme dans plusieurs
milieux évangéliques
aujourd'hui
où il n'y a aucune
il n'y a qu'un sens
de privilège
en dire papa
lorsqu'on comprend
que nous sommes
devant un feu dévorant
un Dieu
trois fois cent
juste
personne ne va
dire papa
personne ne peut
arriver
au lieu
treissant
en tombant
des parachutes
s'il n'a pas traversé
la triomphe
et les cent lieux
avant de rentrer
dans les cent de sang
il n'a pas expérimenté
la vraie conversion
c'est pas
mon papa
et toutes ces paroles
méleuses
des chants évangéliques
de nos jours
une intimité
très charnelle
mais c'est lui
qui a traversé
la triomphe
conviction de péché
compris que Christ
était son agneau pascal
et qui a rentré
dans les cent lieux
tremblant
et qui a accédé
à la chambre
intérieure
de la présence
de Dieu
lui il peut dire
papa
et qui est capable
de nous conduire
par ces chemins
c'est qui
est le Saint-Esprit
c'est qui est le Saint-Esprit
qui peut faire
ce travail double
où il nous conduit
à dire
un bas père
et en même temps
il fait le retour
verset 16
et l'Esprit lui-même
rend témoignage
à notre esprit
qui nous sommes
enfants des dieux
or si nous sommes
nous sommes aussi
héritiers
héritiers des dieux
et co-héritiers
des Christ
si toutefois
nous souffrons
avec lui
afin d'être glorifiés
j'estime
que les souffrances
du temps présent
ne sauront être
comparées
à la gloire à venir
qui sera révélée en nous
et nous connaissons
la suite
des romans
chapitre 8
où il va défendre
qu'aucune chose
n'a la capacité
de séparer
un vrai enfant des dieux
de l'amour des dieux
le fruit de l'esprit
il est permanent
et c'est la permanence
du fruit de l'esprit
qui assure
non seulement
la conversion légitime
mais qui assure
aussi
la permanence
du chrétien
Christ
c'est l'arbre
l'illustration
c'est les fruits
de l'agriculture
le Saint-Esprit
il y a quelque part
cette sève
qui coule
nous sommes une branche
qui était
morte
mauvaise
qui ne faisait
qu'éporter
des mauvais fruits
mais nous avons été
greffés
à cette vigne
c'est le Saint-Esprit
lui-même
qui nous a
connectés à Christ
et Dieu n'est pas
en train de prendre
des risques
dans cet érancissement
qui était
à l'origine
du plan
de la rédemption
c'est celui
qui n'a jamais
planifié
aucune chose
de manière imparfaite
douter
que Dieu soit capable
de planifier
les choses
de manière si parfaite
à point
que ceux qui l'ont
sauvés
ne vont pas perdre
le salut
c'est de douter
de la sagesse
de Dieu
c'est une offense
à Dieu
mais à quel coup
Dieu a développé
ses plans de salut
c'est en investissant
son fils lui-même
donc il a élu
donc l'élection
c'est aussi
une autre doctrine
qui nous montre
clairement
l'impossibilité
de la perte
du salut
et Dieu a établi
un plan
où il a dû
investir
et c'est clair
que Dieu
n'est pas en train
de prendre du risque
dans cet investissement
vous êtes avec moi ?
s'il va investir
son tout
son fils
bien-aimé
la moindre possibilité
qu'un seul
d'entre nous
soit plus fort
ou plus sage
qu'est Dieu
pour considérer
qu'on aurait
la capacité
de frustrer Dieu
dans les plans
de me sauver
de vous sauver
nous sommes en train
d'ouvrir
la possibilité
pour toujours
que toutes les personnes
aient cette capacité
et comme dit
l'apôtre Paul
donc Christ est mort
avant
Christ aurait envoyé
son fils
bien-aimé
pour mourir
à la croix
pour souffrir
l'enfer
à ma place
sans que son oeuvre
soit efficace
on doute
de la sagesse
de Dieu
on doute
de la puissance
des dieux
on doute
même
de l'organisation
du plan de salut
on doute
de la capacité
de Christ
est-ce que
Christ n'a pas
souffert assez
et donc
les fils
il est venu
pour accomplir
une oeuvre
parfaite
la mathématique
c'était une science
exacte
à cet égard
c'était une
transaction légale
où toute
demande
de la loi
des dieux
envers nous
devrait être
parfaitement
accomplie
et tous les péchés
qu'on avait commis
qui les élus
avaient commis
et qui allont
encore commettre
devraient être
comptabilisés
et déversés
en termes
de punition
sur les Christ
à la croix
voilà pourquoi
il va mourir
dans 3 heures
lorsqu'il aurait pu
mourir
pendant 4-5 jours
c'était une souffrance
spirituelle
au-delà
c'était un enfer
condensé
déversé sur lui
et lorsqu'il
Christ monte
en tant que
suprême
sacrificateur
il porte avec lui
cette oeuvre
parfaite
son antecession
comme j'ai déjà dit
n'est pas une intercession
des supplications
c'est une intercession
pour réclamer
l'efficacité
de ce qu'il a fait
il n'y a pas de risque
dans cette transaction
Dieu
les pères
les fils
et les Saint-Esprit
sont engagés
dans cette affaire
et ici
nous sommes devant
surtout
les rôles
du Saint-Esprit
et selon
l'intentionnalité
des dieux
les rôles particuliers
du Saint-Esprit
dans ses plans
de rédemption
donc on a considéré
tout ce que
les pères a fait
les fils a fait
des choses
qui peuvent
ne pas nous toucher
directement
même si ça nous touchait
déjà avant
notre conversion
il est mort
pour moi
même que je n'étais
pas encore conscient
sauf que
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
rentre
dans l'affaire
c'est pour
appliquer
cette réalité
et le Saint-Esprit
est envoyé
pour appliquer
non seulement
pour produire
la conversion
pour nous faire
comprendre
de quelle manière
nous sommes adoptés
en tant qu'enfants
des dieux
mais il fait
de nous
enfants des dieux
le Saint-Esprit
venant
est appelé
par les pères
par les fils
par les nouveaux
testaments
comme
attention
les sceaux
la sémence
qui ne peut pas
flertrir
il est appelé
cette sémence
immortelle
par laquelle
on a été
engendré
il est appelé
selon Christ
comme celui
qui vient
demeurer
éternellement
en nous
il est appelé
les gages
de notre
héritage
pourquoi
les êtres
humains
donnent des gages
lorsqu'ils font
une affaire
car on sait
qu'on a les risques
de l'infidélité
d'une des parties
et on veut avoir
la moindre
et que ça soit
importante
assurance
garantie
sauf que
Dieu ne peut
pas mentir
mais par sa grâce
il a scellé
non seulement
avec les saints
de son propre fils
notre alliance
avec lui
mais il nous a scellé
en envoyant
un gage
qui ne peut pas
se perdre
un gage
qui a pour but
et fonction
nous assurer
d'être sauvés
jusqu'à ce qu'il revienne
pour accomplir
pleinement l'oeuvre
qu'il a commencée
donc la permanence
du Saint-Esprit
est la raison
fondamentale
non seulement
pourquoi
nous sommes sauvés
mais c'est
les fondements
de notre assurance
de savoir
que nous allons
finir bien
la carrière
je ne sais pas
dans quel moment
dans la foi
vous êtes aujourd'hui
si vous avez
souffert l'assaut
des judaïsants
des faux prophètes
si vous traversez
l'insécurité
de la foi
peut-être que vous n'avez
jamais expérimenté
on va dire
de manière expérimentale
ces réalités
et c'est à vous
de supplier devant Dieu
!
de l'avoir
car sans ça
on n'arrive pas
à la pleine assurance
du salut
supplier
que la foi
soit expérimentale
que je sois non
en train de vivre
la foi de ma mère
ou de ma grand-mère
mais de connaître Dieu
au fond de mon cœur
de l'aimer
d'expérimenter
cette paix
cette réconciliation
peu importe
quelle soit
notre condition actuelle
c'est que la Bible
nous enseigne
c'est qu'il s'égage
qu'il y a
le Saint-Esprit
dans nos vies
nous assure
que son influence
ne va jamais
désister
que celui
qui a commencé
l'œuvre en nous
va mener à terme
que l'Écrit
ce qui est l'auteur
et consommateur
de la foi
a envoyé
son Saint-Esprit
pour habiter en nous
afin de nous redresser
afin
de booster
notre sanctification
par
les influences
de révéler
de plus en plus
Christ en nous
et à nous
reproduire la vie
de Christ en nous
et à travers nous
aux autres
par la grâce
des dieux
avec
les temps
d'expérience
pastorale
que j'ai
j'ai pu déjà
constater
la persévérance
du Saint-Esprit
dans les vies
des croyants
la Bible
en appelant
on voit par exemple
les cas de Pierre
qui a rebondi
sur une grande chute
pour devenir
encore plus robuste
dans sa foi
et c'est très intéressant
de remarquer
comment plusieurs personnes
sont restaurées
dans la foi
non car
à un moment donné
dans leur vie
dans leur éloignement
dans les pires moments
de leur foi
ils ont été menacés
de perdre
les paradis
d'être chassés
et notamment
car le Saint-Esprit
a agi puissamment
pour les restaurer
que ce soit
par ses influences
douces
que ce soit
par sa discipline
sévère
les vrais chrétiens
seront toujours
redressés
restaurés
et il va toujours
être développé
dans sa foi
car le Dieu
qui a décidé
de nous sauver
n'a pas pris de risque
il a tout investi
et il a voyé
la troisième personne
de la Sainte Trinité
pour faire cette œuvre
en nous
Amen
et vends-nous pour prier
de la Sainte Trinité